David Pollock ESPN college football
analyst ESPN seven hours of pregame
coverage live from New Orleans today
college gameday at Three Championship
Drive at six Nick Saban will be a guest
analyst on Championship Drive as we
welcome in David Pauley hi David
what's up guys I did not foresee any
Rutgers talk on championship Monday I
didn't see that comin wait you didn't
prep for this no I did in ballet
remember Rutgers was in the bigge set so
we're expecting any kind of you know
miracle now with Rutgers being in the
big ten Schiano and a great return I
think you better tend for those
expectations or that they don't save you
okay but has North Dakota State become
too good yeah I think what man when you
watch that game the other day and I'm a
football junkie I got problems J mu was
a better team but North Dakota State had
trail ants like they had the Walter
Payton Award the Heisman Trophy winner
for that division and you can just tell
he was a different third and 23 taking
off and scrambling and for a fake field
goal for a touchdown like Nate I don't
even think that was the times where they
were most dominant team but they still
found a way to win in a rebuilding year
for them so just with that kid at
quarterback by the way for the next two
or three or four years however many
years he's going to be there they're
gonna continue to win championships
because he was clearly better than
everybody else on the field there wasn't
close that's all I wanted to talk to you
about David I didn't really care about
the national title game just wanted do
you think if Trevor Lawrence wins
tonight dot-dot-dot he's gonna start up
himself in the conversation for the
grace of all time you know I mean you're
talking about two seasons back-to-back
you know the Clemson Tigers are than 30
you know now he didn't start four games
I think the year before that
or three games that person here but man
he's going to start for themselves in
that conversation by the way they're
gonna be back again you know next year
in the playoffs that they EC is you know
it is what it is worse than the worst
conference in college football but five
and Clemson there is no other remote
challenger that can even I mean Clemson
is going to be a 20-point favor in
almost every single game so it's
definitely
not a league that's going to challenge
him but it's definitely in big-time
moments until how said he stepped up and
ran the football and made plays and had
a huge comeback and then if you get beat
show bro who by the way is having the
best you know season probably of any
quarterback you can ever think of in one
of the most miraculous turnaround in
their City it would definitely go a long
way to start in that conversation for
one more year of Trevor Lawrence and
being the greatest of all time this game
tonight will come down to what have a
field goal kicker that would be great
and all this NFL cow it all these
playmakers our number one pick in the
draft next year the number one taking
the draft this year and a dadgum kicker
will be the difference and it'll be
41:38 type of game I think it's going to
be I think it's going to be it's going
to be a lot of fun it's going to be a
lot of scoring I think a lot of people
according to Ohio State's defense
shutting down Clemson are slowing them
down and unless you have the potential
to do the same I don't think LSU has the
same dude Ohio State has in the trenches
and I think I think it's going to be a
lot of fun I think both backs are going
to really have great days with gliding
with Delayer and Travis you can both
those guys are going to make plays the
quarterback is going to make plays the
wide receiver is gonna make plays I
guess one thing you could point to to it
he's gonna make a mistake and we haven't
seen Joe Burrell make you know baby just
season and we haven't seen Trevor Lord
make one in a hot minute I mean he did
earlier the year and didn't look like he
went through his struggles early a year
but the last you know eight games
mistakes have not been not been very
many yeah I'm kind of mixed on this that
LSU their skilled position those wide
receivers and even their corners are
some of the most incredible athletes
I've seen on a football field in a long
long time and then I come back to Dabo
Sweeney you know he's been playing this
underdog role I like Clemson tonight I
don't know why but I just I've gotten
that feeling that I I like Clemson to
come up with a big moment here help me
with that why do I like Clemson well I
mean they proven it time and time again
everybody I mean they've won two out of
the last three they're now listen the
underdog role is driving me nuts 29
games bro you
no more like I just need the chip on the
shoulder you know nobody respects upcard
no nobody affects your league like
everybody respects Clemson nobody was
text who you play week in and week out
the Davos of even a magazine coaching by
the way has a chance to cement
themselves tonight I mean it's the
greatest coach in college football
usually take that thrown away from from
Nick Saban right I mean nice are you
taking that away well I'm just saying if
you win tonight that's three of the last
four national championship you can't
tell me saving the best coaching House
football we haven't if he's won one at a
last four I mean so I think dad was
definitely going I think you have to
appreciate and this is probably what you
look at them you probably appreciate
just the way they do it because yeah I
didn't think anybody else I think you
could win a national championship unless
you were very in-your-face like Urban
Meyer and Nick Saban these guys I
thought you had to be that type of coach
I didn't think you could really do it
with fun you know and then Davos proved
us all wrong and he does it with
relationships and he loves his guys and
they kick it and they have fun and they
dance and they make it a celebration and
make it a lot of fun they've done a
great job with that and we continue to I
think me like the brand of Clemson it's
just fun to watch and it's fun to it's
easy to cheer for they're just it seems
like they go about their business and
not a lot of shuttle boating not a lot
of glitz and glam they just go out and
win and off the field and give gift
glory and then cut they may keep going
who are you picking you can't ask me
that question no I think I Phoebe dad
I'm going the Tigers but no I think it
just feels it to me it feels like a
magical year for LSU and and I haven't I
haven't studied a quarterback that that
so an officer I haven't studied an
offense in my time at ESPN that I didn't
have an answer like I'm always full of
answers and I'm full of opinions and I'm
loud obnoxious that's why I'm on TV but
you know I just I haven't seen the
solution all burned did a good job
several times with Jabbar and then once
he figured out it was like he had peace
out bro so you know Venables with with
with all this time to prepare and can it
can he be the one to put together a play
I just I haven't seen it yet and Clemson
if I'm gonna pick on you know
deficiencies with them but you know no
not having a hunter Renfro over the
middle of the field you know a guy that
can attack the middle of the field
really really well
it's gonna be on Lawrence running the
football it's gonna be on EPM catching
the ball back to you both those guys are
more than capable but I think Jill
Burrell has more more weapons a bigger
Arsenal and I think Clyde Edward de
l'air has a big data galaxy has a big
day but I tell you I think it's 41:38
that game are you gonna ask Savin why he
didn't recruit you
no I understand why come on now hey you
were a first rounder in a thick I'm not
asking that we'll asking 40 of questions
that it'll be interesting to watch Nick
by the way talk about I'm ready I'm
little to be beside I mean I'm gonna be
like hey Nick so what did you do to try
to stop travel right I know what did you
do this hey it should be fun and your
day is starting soon there we appreciate
your time David all the best tonight
that's David Pollock I got seven hours
of pregame coverage from New Orleans
college gameday at 3 championship drive
at 6:00 and then the title game coming
up later on tonight for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]